mais pendant vous allez vous mettre en
place je crois que il ya aussi des gens
avec qui vous avez l'habitude de
travailler
c'est christophe salengro et ricardo oui
ils nous ont rejoints oui mais voilà
déjà parlé des textes de filles venues
des langages qui est dans les pièces qui
est de la danse mais il ya aussi un
autre mode d'expression là comme on sait
changer dans les coulisses pendant ce
temps là le truc non on a parlé de
cotation les jeux on n'a pas parlé
justement vous attendez pourra parler
moi je veux des jugements qu'avec
philippe y avait toujours des problèmes
de texte que c'était plutôt des noms
texte en fait et voilà pour parler des
textes dans les pièces de philips est
plutôt des noms texte en dehors des non
dits qu'il ya aussi dans la dans la
pièce où danser les petits précédé aussi
et placide
ce moment c'est eric ou de l'opa à ce
look
excusez moi on a essayé de on a essayé
de on a cherché textes de jeunes trépied
ou par de dures ou
pas jaloux le mosoni de bâle par exemple
que philippe avait trouvé et des textes
qui parlait un peu de la perception du
monde et ça durera du rapport entre les
mots et les choses et on est parti sur
donc sur cette recherche de cette
recherche sur les mots en perdant
général et on a fait donc on est arrivé
à travers eux on a commencé à le prendre
avec cruciani quitte un futuriste un
futuriste qui a écrit on avait fourni
les travailler sur un salut tartare et
ensuite on a on va travailler sur des
nous les christian saraki mois sur la
pression que j'avais déjà et on avait on
avait plutôt travailler sur un autre
texte dit et moi j'imagine que ça monte
à courir
compper en lui beaucoup pointent vers le
chu de musique de l'état par hector
pesant contre un contenant en tout cas
si j'avais le temps je leur laisserai
faire là ça s'est super je peux pas donc
bien on le sait pas on les applaudit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]